welcome back everyone to the morning
session so we're going to have the
second talk again on traffic system
problem and descent velocity yeah thank
you very much and thanks for the
organizers for inviting me and giving
the one-hour slot and also thanks very
much for shadowing me after David who
gave like an excellent overview of what
we currently know about TSP so this is
joint work we will have spent Sun and
Yaqoob ton of sky both from epfl they
are not here now but both of them will
be around for some time later this
workshop also so now in an hour I'll
kind of I hope I can give you the big
picture and like explain what are the
components here and how they relate to
each other but there seem to be some
interest to here like more technical
details and actual proofs as opposed to
the kind of hand wavy arguments you'll
see here so I give a whiteboard talk
with more details sometime next week
it's probably at 10:30 on Monday but
this will send an email around that
about that so the TSP as we all know is
the problem we have and cities and we
are given the pairwise distances we want
to find a shortest tour connecting all
the cities for example this is one by
Bill Cook visiting all the pubs in the
UK so yeah I don't think I need to say
much more about the problem after
David's talk I just want to highlight
the relevant aspect here so we can talk
about symmetric versus asymmetric TSP in
the asymmetric TSP the distance from I
to J can be very different from J to I
like if you cycle around Berkeley or
even more around San Francisco than
it's definitely relevant so if you are
like working for a cycle delivery
company in San Francisco you definitely
want to go with a TSP in all cases we
will assume that triangle inequality
holds that is if we add an extra stop at
K between I and J then we cannot do
better than going from directly from I
to J if we don't assume triangle
inequality the problem becomes really
hard so for the rest we will work under
this assumption so I just give you like
very few of the relevant results just
focusing on the basic cyclic TSP
variance so for symmetric TSP as we have
seen in the previous thought there is
this stubborn one-point-five
approximation which is still the best
since Christofias
work in the 70s however it seems that if
we kind of look at special cases which
have like a combinatorial structure
where the metric is generated by the
shortest path metric of a graph then we
can do substantially or somewhat better
so here like the current best is 1.4 as
opposed to 1.5 which builds on like a
sequence of papers by obvious current
Siberian singham contention and mukha
and the current best is Shibuya and
vegan so let us and that that's all I
wanted to say about the symmetric TSP so
for asymmetric the long time so it's the
in terms of approximability we are much
further away so like the for a very long
time the best was the logan
approximation by Frascati and Maffeo li
this is a
like a very beautiful simple algorithm I
will give you an overview if this is the
first in the unlikely case this is the
first time you encounter a TSP done
probably that's like a very very good
take from the talk the this log n
approximation it's actually no big oh
here it's an actual to base log Emin
like there was a sequence of words just
trying to improve on the constant before
this slogan so it's already that was
quite a non-trivial challenge and then
the real breakthrough came by this work
by Assad Porgy menagerie and obvious
Karen and Siberia because majority of
the authors is in the room yeah I think
most people in the audience did spend
some time days or years during their
lives working on TSP and we have most
people in the references in the audience
it really feels great to give this talk
here
so this broke below the logon by a
factor log log on and they introduced
this approach using thin trees which
David talked about a bit and I'm not
going to go into this but so so far like
the best previous general result was by
Nima and Shayan which gave like poly log
log and bound on the integrality gap so
this is not constructive in the sense
that it doesn't give an algorithm only
the proof that the integrity gap is
bounded and this uses all this deep cut
it's on singer machinery and actually
using this same thing she approached all
so we can get better for some special
cases so let me highlight what are the
that the best previous case is noon
where we had constant factor
approximation so again as in the
symmetric TSP what kind of makes a
difference like the the interesting
special cases where we can get better is
if we have like a graph structure so if
our problem is given by a metric in a
bounded genus graph then again
NIM and Cheyenne can give a constant
factor approximation and with a very
different approach which was like a very
sorry yeah so you are looking kind of
confused and I was varied that I'm
getting something wrong here but and
which is the case um so so I had this
previous paper which was on node
weighted a TSP which is like the
simplest case would be just a directed
graph shortest path metric it's slightly
more general than that I'll come to more
detail on this problem and so this is
like a very combinatorial approach it
doesn't use thin trees so it develops a
general machinery which has seemed to
have the potential to work beyond this
case of nude weighted graphs but it was
kind of non-trivial to make it work in
fact we had the previous paper three of
us very good push this approach for two
different edge weights
now the that's a like a quite a
complicated paper the good news is that
the general thing is actually kind of
simpler than just this two edge weight
I'll try to highlight why
what's the reason for that so now that
we are going to continue on these lines
and like using this approach from good
as 2015 paper we are going to give a
constant factor approximation for
general a TSP and then the approximation
ratio actually in all the papers
mentioned is with respect to the health
care products session so I'm not going
to tell you the constant right now I
guess it already leaked and this but
yeah so that will only come at the end
of the talk if you make it until then so
let me now specify the exact formulation
of a TSP we are working with so this is
like kind of equivalent to the general
metric a TSP but has like an underlying
graph in the formulation so we are given
a directed graph with non-negative edge
weights and we want to find a minimum
weight tool in this graph so what does
that mean
a tool is a closed walk which visits
every vertex at least one so like if you
are like kind of very conservative about
the problem definition you could require
to visit every vertex exactly one if you
think of metric a TSP then you could
like shortcut the this tool and get that
kind of form but but this is like more
convenient for us to work with so an
equivalent way of looking at this it is
that we have a multi subset of edges you
can use the same edge multiple times
which is at the same time you Lillian
which means that the in degree of every
vertex is equal to did its out degree
and that it is connected once you have a
Nigerian and connected set it's a simple
exercise to show that you can always
convert it into a tour
it's every nerd at least once and then
another important concept will use is
the sub tour which it's not exactly what
I meant here so this will be like a
illyrian and connected edge multi set on
a subset of the nodes not on the entire
nuit set yeah so let's just solve an
actual atsp instance right here
so these are the weights on the edges
and then we can get away not using this
super expensive edge however like as you
can see this five edge will be used
twice that's what they mean by an area
and multi set of edges and this is the
optimal solution on this little instance
so let me get to the Hult carp
relaxation so this is like the canonical
very natural relaxation for both the
directed and undirected cases so we have
variables x e on the edges where which
are like ideally is supposed to be
integer and expresses the multiplicity
of this edge in the selected tour so we
want to minimize the cost of X subject
to two sets of constraints so the first
is that we want an o'leary and set of
factors like the so this means that the
summing up the X values on all incoming
edges to be it should equal the sum of
the X values on all outgoing edges from
me the second constraint is the subtour
elimination constraints we use it in a
somewhat non-standard but equivalent
variant so although this is directed TSP
we look at the undirected degree of asad
so which is the total that the set of
incoming and outgoing edges together and
we want the total
x value on them to be at least two now
assuming the illyrian constraint so you
can see that for every set the total of
incoming flow is the same as a total
outgoing flow so this really means that
both the incoming and the outgoing
should be at least one so however like
it will be more convenient for our
arguments to work with like a constraint
of a symmetric form and we also want non
negativity right so we know that this
can be solved in polynomial time which
is not immediate because we have an
exponential number of constraints for
every subset of vertices we require that
some flow should be going in and out in
fact the best lower bound on the
integrality gap is again by people
present in the audience um and well our
constant is still a long way from here
so there is still much much scope for
improvement so just I think it's kind of
helpful visualization of what's going on
in this health care products session we
have three things really which we would
expect from an 80s P so you should be
oil aryan it should be connected and it
should be integral now if you pick any
two from these three you're in business
so all three together would be a TSP
integral and connected that we can like
suboptimal it that's the spanning tree
integral and I'll Aryan that psycho
cover which get to on the next few
slides and I'll Aryan and connected is
but relaxing integrality is the health
cart relaxation so the kind of the like
high-level first question in any a TSP
algorithm is that we want to have these
three things all together we want to
start with two and relax the third like
what shall we
so like the
Christel PDS approach which is like on a
high level follow is followed by thin
trees is to focus on connectivity and
relax the illyrian constraints start
with a spanning tree and kind of try to
fix the oil area and property and then
the question is how do you select your
spanning tree so in the approach you use
however it's more like the following the
original free Scabbia timothy only
approach when we relaxed connectivity
and go with cycle covers we try to build
a TSP tour i like sowing cycle covers
together so let me start with this free
sky BRT my fuel a very simple and
beautiful algorithm so first we want to
find a minimum weight cycle cover so
what is that we want to find a set of
edges which is illyrian and covers every
vertex at least one in the health care
products session we remove this up to
our constraints which means that our
solution may end up not being connected
however since this gives you a like a
minimum cost circulation problem we have
always an integral optimal solution in
fact the health carb solution gives us a
fractional solution so we know that the
integral solution cannot be worse than
the that and the cost of the health carp
optimum and then what we do we find our
first solution if it's connected we are
really happy if it's not then we sort of
like collapse each of the components we
obtain and thereby since every cycle
they contain at least two vertices even
in the most pessimistic case we have the
number of components in the graph and
then we keep iterating this we always
have the number of components so that's
why we get log 2n rounds in each round
the
corresponding like circulation problem
has cost and was the optimum so that's
why we we got the log and factor and
this slogan is kind of very difficult to
do to get beyond so that's what kind of
rulers approach was originally is to
instead of looking at this natural
simple cycle cover problem which would
just make sure that every vertex is
connected he looks at like a somewhat
more subtle sub problem and reduces
general a TSP to the solution of this
program so this problem is called local
connectivity a TSP so I'll tell you a
bit later but this exactly is and what
this light thing here means but
basically if one has an so called alpha
light algorithm for local connectivity a
TSP then there is some black box
machinery which gives us a nine of
approximation for general idea so now
this is not limited to any specific
structure whenever you are able to
implement this local connectivity a TSP
with a constant lightness on your class
of instance is done you get the constant
factor approximation for a TSP so what
will I did was to implement well that
the first service this black box
reduction and then for the class of node
weighted graphs it is something fairly
easy to implement I'll go through that
later today so what is the node weighted
ats-v I have a number written on each of
the vertices and then the cost of every
edge is the sum of the weights of the
two endpoints
I'm not yes so this is the question I
was expecting because so in ullas
original paper it's actually just age of
V and what is kind of strange in this
form is that it is indeed symmetric but
note that the graph is not complete so
if we have between two vertices going
arcs in both ways they do have the same
cost if but the more interesting case is
that we only have like isometrics pairs
of vertices and so another like quick
exercise is that if like this model
putting the widths of booths and princes
equivalent to putting weights only on
either the starting point or on the end
for him because in if you look at an oil
area and set of fattiest and these
things will kind of all aggregate to the
same so that's like a little exercise
you can think about so anyway so this is
I wrote it in this form because it's
kind of closer to the the variant we
will look at later all right so any
questions so far
so then I have the roadmap of there is 9
times 3 27 is 9 times 3 so it's a 3 line
so I will show it with 2 although it
will be like for a restricted case but
you will be able to find out how that 3
is obtained so this is the road map if
it might look scary but I kind of first
try to tell you what's like the general
idea behind this whole thing so we have
like this is what Swensen gives us if we
have like a class of a TSP instances
then we can reduce it to if on this
class we can find a constant light
algorithm for local connectivity it has
to be whatever local connectivity it a
sphere is then we are in business so
what kind of we we tried for a long time
and that's what we did for the to wait
case is just to try to engineer this
constant light or a call for like
general problem instance and that's what
we managed to do for 2 different edge
weights but even like for 3 that didn't
seem like an approach anyone would want
to go down but then so what's the key
here is that we have like a series of
reductions to like a special structured
a TSP instances so there is this vector
breed pairs which we are beyond a TSP
instance plus a software we have already
bought during the way which kind of
helps with most of the critical cost
component in the connectivity so what we
do we will get down to these vertebrate
instances where this local connectivity
a TSP finally becomes something within
reach now what I will focus on the talk
today is like the first part which just
sets the stage on what kind of instances
are we working with
it is basically LP duality then I'll
just skip this part and move to this
constant light algorithm on vertebrate
paths which is like the final part of
the proof now what happens in between
it's kind of a series of natural
reductions like we define reducible and
irreducible instances where we can recur
stew-like smaller instances via
contractions and and still lose some
constant factors on the way but we don't
care about this is like very graph
theoretical combinatorial arguments and
then for these irreducible instances we
can transform them into these vertebrate
paths and so I'll just give you like a
few hints about what's going on in this
middle part of the the proofs and then
I'm happy to give more details next day
right so let's get started with just
setting the stage this will be just LP
duality so here is the Healthcare
Products session and here is the duals
so what does the dual have we have a
variable alpha corresponding to every
vertex and we have a variable Y
corresponding to every set note that
like if you have a vertex you have the
Alpha but it's also present as like a
singlet and set so it will also have a
y-value for for the sets like for the
value of the singlet an and then there
we have like covering constraints here
we have packing constraints so for every
edge UV we sum up the total y-values
crossed by the surge plus we add the
starting point and subtract that the
endpoint of the for the alpha values and
our objective is to maximize the sum of
the Y values for twice because we had
that coefficient to die
now again there is some like details
about how we can how to solve this duo
but it can be solved in polynomial time
in fact and that will be crucial for us
one can always find an optimal solution
where the support is on a laminar family
of sets now just to prove the existence
of a laminar solution that's kind of
very simple you just do like a standard
down crossing arguments if you have like
two crossing sets in your family and you
replace them by the intersection and the
union then like these covering
constrains can only get better objective
won't change so like you can definitely
make progress now if you want to make
this efficient that's kind of a nice
problem by itself how can you like on
cross like a family of sets in
polynomial time under certain rules so
it's that they're been quite a few
papers on these problems at the one
relevant for us is like a ninety six
paper by Carson of which gives us like a
polynomial time algorithm to find such
an actress in okay so so we have this
relaxation and this will like motivate
the definition of an instant so when we
speak about an 80s be instance well like
the the of course in the first place we
would take a graph and the weight
function and that's what defines our
instance but here we reduce them to like
the this quadrupole of four things so
that I just write it here for reference
and instance as a graph has a family of
sets as a health Corp solution and has a
dual solution so G is a directed graph
new offer yeah I'll get there so L is a
laminar family of subsets of V X is a
health Corp solution on G and X E is
positive for any edge and Y is a vector
associate positive value to every set in
L and we also have that every set with
respect to
every set in the lemon our family has
exactly two units of flu like one unit
incoming one unit outgoing that's what
we call a tight set now from what I said
that you can always find a lemon or dual
solution we are almost there to get such
an instance the only thing is exactly
that there are these alphas in the dual
which we have to get rid of so yes so
the induced weight function will be so
that the weight of an edge UV is the sum
of the Y values of the edges cross by
this set so for example there is this
edge it crosses like this 4 plus 12 plus
4 plus 5 that gives us 25 this one
crosses SATs only on one side 8 plus 3
plus 12 it's 23 again our laminar family
can have single atoms in it as well as
larger sets so we see that actually if
the laminar family only has single
attest and this is just the sum of the
two endpoints so we are back at the node
weighted case and it also has the same
property Ravi asked about is that it's
symmetric but it's again it's not really
symmetric because in the graph we might
have an edge in one way but not in the
other so how do we get such an instance
so we solve health Corp get a lemon or
remove all zero edges and then the only
little observation which is kind of the
same observation you need to get move
between the two versions of the of the
node weighted definition is that if I
and this is true just because of the
illyrian property if I modify my cost
function by shifting it on the endpoints
by Arthur so on for every uvv add half
of e and subtract alpha you for
arbitrary numbers you then the cost of
any area so you
remains the same right so we add the say
at every node if you look at incoming
and outgoing edges we at the same and
subtract the same so we got the the the
exact center that's why the office went
away yeah and we also yes so here we use
complementary sickness for this we don't
need slackness that's just like the I
lyrium property yeah so okay so these
are the instances we work with and it's
kind of so the motivation was to try to
stay as close to the node weighted case
as possible here we kind of have this
good understanding what the cost of an
edge depends on its we have this laminar
family it's exactly the the values of
the sets our edge crosses so is the
definition of an instance clear and
again it's just kind of simple
corollaries of complementary slackness
and having a laminar dual solution so
let me fast forward you to the very end
of the the whole process and let me show
you how this constant light local
connectivity a TSP invertebrate
pass is implemented for which I first
have to tell you about local
connectivity at the SBS and what a
vertebrate pair is so let me start with
a vertebrate pair so this is a pair of
an instance and a subtour so again like
it's really like five things we have
this GL XY plus I already have a set of
edges which I somehow got on this long
way of reductions which is called the
backbone so this is a subtour which
crosses every non singlet and tide set
in my family L so here these are like
singlet ends in L I don't cross them in
general I don't care about singlet ends
and let's assume that someone already
gave me such an excerpt which is like
constant factor times the optimal
solution so why why is this something
good so yes
true respects the the edges of each yes
so it's a directed yes yes it is a
directed absolutely yeah so it's obvious
when I mean a subtour that's like a
decent directed subtour J or sorry so it
is like this is the particular relation
I have l so this is part of this I like
that's like these four things together
and then that the property I expect is
that every non singlet and set in L is
crossed is that the question it's only
the Pendergraft because we just can use
the edges of the graph and later on we
will also impose like a bound on the
cost but let's let's not get there yet
okay so again what goes in and out from
every set in that I mean our family so
what's the kind of the motivation behind
looking at these instances so first of
all that comes out kind of naturally in
the reduction steps that's how we arrive
to them in the first place but kind of
like if you have an edge which like sits
outside here or like if it doesn't cross
and is set in the family then it's
exactly like a node weighted edge it
just takes the costs of the two end
points so that's the kind of edges we
are already like very familiar veed and
knew how to deal with them in allows all
technique now the of course also need to
cross these sets back and forth if we
really want to solve a TSP but then for
induce edges will eat up all the costs
of these sets so so we have like much
less control and understanding on them
but somehow this backbone will do all
their jobs like it will kind of
make all the covering we need from these
edges of who we cannot control the cost
and so kind of that stuff that's the
intuition why these are helpful
instances hopefully like the that the
proof will shed some light on what this
really means any any more questions here
okay so so that's what we all do there
is a little cheating on this slide but
for for the purpose of the talk we can
imagine that all these reductions give
us a backbone which is in the same
ballpark as the optimal solution and
then we'll solve local connectivity ATS
be on such instances and then Pam use
allows blackbox reduction so finally
here is local connectivity at the SB so
to properly define the problem it's it's
kind of a bit subtle so we have an
instance we have these induced edge
weights which are the sum of the Y
values and then there is a lower bound
function given on the vertices it's
actually up to us to define this lower
bound function so that's kind of also
like part of of what we we have to do in
in the problem so this gives a weight to
each of the vertices such that it sums
up to the optimum value so the simplest
case and that's what gula uses in the
nude weighted case is simply to look at
every vertex look at the total
fractional weight of all the edges
arriving at this vertex and then assign
this weight as the lower bound to this
vertex so that clearly is partitions the
distributes the optimum among the
vertices now we will need to do
something more subtle for vertebrate
paths but that's like kind of the
starting point so the induced weights in
this instance we are looking at will be
like
have these Y values and then we sum up
the values on the so exactly this
definition here but again it would like
the slow cotton activity a TSP would
work for like even without this
structure like it doesn't assume
anything you say the induced waits for
edges yes exactly I mean the sync single
notes can or cannot be may or may not be
in the laminar familia
I mean if it's between two vertices that
neither of them is in the laminar
feminists just zero yeah yeah okay so
what we will have that we have to fix
these lower bounds for good and then in
every iteration the Oracle will give us
a partition of the vertices into V 1 V 2
V K and then it expects as the output
and our Larian set of edges it doesn't
have to be connected it doesn't have to
cover everyone the requirement is that
it must cross every set in this
partition okay so here like these two
sets at sets go through every one they
are not connected there is like a whole
world completely uncovered so this okay
so of course we can always output a
Nigerian exit as such the important
requirement will be and this is where
this alpha light comes into play so for
every connected component of this
solution if I look at the total cost of
the edges of this component it should be
at most of times the total lower bound
it is able to connect on the vertices in
particular if you are in the low key
situation of having constant factor a
TSP algorithm which is like an alpha
factor that already gives you an awful I
toggle rhythm because then the total
weight it connects is exactly the
optimal solution there is just one giant
connected components so this is kind of
a real
session of of 80s we call it light
because it's not really well-defined
approximation problem but we want to
make sure kind of that every like it's
it's like a cost sharing kind of thing
like every component is able to afford
paying for the edges within this
component you return constant factor ETA
speciation that it satisfies this so
then like that's a tour which has a
single connected component yes so f is
the edge set which I returned the lower
bound of the component is the lower
bound of everyone all together which
sums up to the optimum value it's not
for the VI so that's important it's not
for the vias it's for F the idea
reinsert V return
okay and then like I don't even attempt
to give you an overview of how like
ullas algorithm works in like it's a
sophisticated way of repeatedly calling
this Oracle and and joining all these
Iberian tours into something which
ultimately ends up being connected but
okay so there is this machinery so we
just have to implement it for like these
vertebrate instances so before doing
that let's just actually forget about
this vertebra the the backbone and let's
assume like that we are in like the nude
weighted case infecting this in a
special case of the node weighted case
because like so if L only contains
singlet ins then we have that the weight
of energy is the sum of the Y values of
the end points but we are kind of in an
even stronger situation because we
whenever a singlet an has a positive Y
value it must have
in and out degree exactly one which is
not required in the nude weighted case
in the nude bit it kills you could have
nodes with more and less than one as the
in and out degree so now I'm going to
present like the the nude weighted
analysis for the simple case and it says
it's like even more special because
every nude bit positively it has its
tight it will be like a to light
algorithm instead of three light so here
kind of the obvious way to define the
lower bounds every node you gets twice
its Y value recall that the optimum
value is the twice the sum of the Y's so
these just nicely sum up to the optimum
so let's take a partition of the
vertices I sneakily added here that all
of them are strongly connected why can
we assume that so if you have like an
arbitrary partition and then if there is
a set which is not strongly connected I
can just look at all its strongly
connected components and then like just
replace it by the strongly connected
components if you look at any sink or
source component among them then if you
cross back and force that said and you
need to cross the big setters right so
that's that's why we can assume that all
of them are strongly connected and now
what we will do is to define a
circulation problem just as in Frisco be
a team of theory but the difference will
be that we don't expect every each and
every node to have like connectivity one
but we create some box alehrer nodes
corresponding to each of the components
and we impose the capacity bounds for
them so how do we create these auxiliary
nodes so we will start by modifying both
the graph and the solution act so here
is a component of in this partition VI
let's say now this has like two units of
flow coming in and going out it's not
tight so now I create this new vertex ai
and I take
like one unit of the incoming and
outgoing flu proportionally distributed
census so that's a total of two put the
half route the half over there all right
so if we do that then these endpoints
will be kind of annoyed because they use
lose Euler ECT so what we do we kind of
proportionally decrease the flu inside
the set meaning that I can kind of look
at like flu decomposition inside the set
yeah of like the whole fractional
solution acts that will connect up like
fractional flus on the incoming and
outgoing edges and then like I
proportionally remove like half or
whatever fraction of all this
decomposition okay so this changes the
graph and F and X we will still have the
illyrian property we won't have anymore
that like every vertex opt or
constraints might be violated including
the single atoms right like they can at
this point have degree less than one but
we don't care about that what we care
about is that this guy has exactly one
unit of incoming and outgoing flow and
now we can look at an integer
circulation problem where we put lower
bounds on the flues on each of the AIS
like just to recall how do we do that
like in in general for a circulation
problem I take the node I split it into
two copies with the incoming and the
outgoing edges and then I can put a
lower capacity bound on the edge between
these two endpoints so this will okay so
now I solve this integer circulation
problem with these lower bounds I can
solve that optimally it will be a
minimum cost solution and compared to
like all the really sophisticated
rounding techniques in all other
algorithms it's worth mentioning that in
all this algorithm that's the only kind
of rounding we are doing we take a
fractional circulation solution and we
round it to an integer solution and then
we will map it back to the original
graph Jesus
get back to exactly what that means but
let's just see what happens here so when
I reroute it the flow I kind of keep the
costs of every arc so I have a feasible
circulation problem of wait optimum so
the flow integrity tells it that this
has cost and was the optimum now how do
I map it back so I will have like at
least or exactly one incoming and
outgoing edge to this set so done I
naturally put these edges back to where
they came from and now I need to make
sure that my solution is Alerian luckily
I assume that the set is strongly
connected so I can just add like any
path between them okay so this is an
arbitrary path it connects them up
that's why every vertex V with a
positive by value I can assume that it
will have in degree Atmos - because
original flow was at most one I can
still impose that it still has flew at
most one and then when I met back I give
it another extra unit so now let's just
do these cost analysis of each component
so for each component I sum up the cost
of all edges which are really the sum of
the two end points and then so every
node correspond contributes its value to
all incoming and outgoing edges of which
you can have at most two for it so it's
at most four times this sum of five
years and then the total lower bound is
twice the sum of five years so that's
why we have a to light algorithm here so
why was in degree at most two yes so I
assumed by complementarity and this is
like not true for general node we did
that if you have a node with positive Y
in the flew it is tight it has sought of
fractional value exactly one so then
like I kind of in the circulation
problem I also can impose without any
harm and upper bound one on the flows
through these vertices so
it's one and the second one is this path
connecting them up okay so so far this
is like Beulah's
analysis for the node weighted case
nothing new has happened so let me now
show how this extends to the case when
we are just one notch further our lemon
our family has a single non-trivial set
but what we do here that's actually kind
of indicative of what happens in the
general case if you understand this then
there is all this carry construction of
split flows which kind of might be
intimidating if you see it for the first
time but it really is just formalizing
the intuition V&V
so recall what the cost is again for
edges not crossing the set it's just a
sum of the two endpoints for edges
crossing the set I need to add in this Y
S which is an extra term so now I
defined a lower bound the following way
for edges I recall I have this set B
which was the backbone now the only
property I care about is that it's an
Iberian edge set which crosses this set
so for every vertex not on the backbone
I just give them their usual dual value
for every vertex on this backbone I
equally distribute the cost of the
backbone now I wanted the total lower
bounds to sum up to the optimum now it
won't quite sum up but it will still be
a constant factor within the optimum
which is good enough because the sum of
these values is at most the optimum and
we assume that the cost of the backbone
is like order of the of the optimum so
this second term is also an order or do
opt ok so this is how I define my lower
bounds
one single yeah that's as could be could
be or I don't know I mean I got it as
part of my input at this stage so be now
I focus on how to solve these vertebrate
pets assuming someone very kindly
provided me a B which crosses everyone
in the laminar family which in this case
is a single thing yep it's more or less
an edge weighted it's more or less than
hydrated just going to do so I this is
kind of the simplest I see maybe there
is something simpler which would be grid
B is connected yet any more question
here we don't checkers fortunately so
this is just one problem
at this stage whistle there are
recursions at others points on the
algorithm but but here we done
actually there is a recursion issue
which I kind of hid in this assumption
which is not quite true but but we can
that's under control um I promise so so
again what I use from this backbone is
it crosses the set therefore there is a
vertex on the backbone which is inside
the cert let's fix this point s and then
it's again kind of a simple flu exercise
to show the following so as recall it's
a tight set with respect to the
fractional solution there is exactly one
unit coming in now I can channel this
one unit of flu to go right to s so it's
kind of a simple max flow min cut cut
condition you can verify so like what do
I mean there is a this flow that I use
the fractional values as the capacities
and and then I'm under this capacity and
now
what we do okay so we will work with
this flow what we actually will do and
it's a bit technical but that the
intuition is that if a unit of flu
enters through one of these edges we
force it to go all the way to as
following this flow we found so the
technical way of doing is to split all
the vertices into two copies one of them
is kind of those who like are like under
pressure to go to us are like indepted
and have to like make sure they reach
this destination and the others are free
to go anywhere and then we can use this
flow to construct this splitting like
like this will be on the amount of the
capacity used in the fluid will be on
one copy of the edge and the other
amount will be used on the other so but
anyways let's let's ignore that what I
want to say is that like we can solve
the aforementioned circulation problem
where I have my input partition and like
I create these auxiliary nodes which are
required to have at least one unit of
flow we can add on the extra constraint
by further like flu machinations so that
whatever enters in the solution through
one of these edges that must must reach
us okay so how do we construct now the
solution so I take my input partition
and to start with I threw in this
backbone so that's a Nigerian set of
Phaedrus that's one thing then the other
one is I solve the circulation problem
with this forcing property and then that
again will be like still just at most
the optimum value so this altogether i
output here will be within a fraction of
the optimum so let me show you like why
does it give us a constant light
algorithm so basically like I have some
of these old innocent components which
do not cross my set as whatsoever for
them the analysis is identical
but to what we had for the nude weighted
case as you well there is this floor
splitting and all that but morally it's
they really just see the cost of the two
end points every vertex pays for for
these edges so they're it's actually a
factor too okay so that's one part of
the components the other I'll have a
giant component that's the one which
contains the backbone and then for I
know that for every edge which enters my
Sata's that must be in the same
component because with this flow we've
forced it to to go there so what the
trick here is that four edges which
behave like nude weighted address we can
use the nude weighted analysis for edges
which they're to cross our satyrs we do
like a brutal overkill but we say that
well this component has lower bound at
least the cost of the this backbone
which we assumed to be in the same
ballpark as the optimum whereas how much
is the cost of this component well it
certainly cannot be more than the cost
of everything which is that the entire
solution still has solution constant
times the optimum so that's why we get a
constant ratio here cost is at most
constant times the optimum even in the
worst case and then there is the lower
bound which is at least a cost of this
vertebra which will again mean they're
right so I'm kind of getting to the end
of my time but I hope I yeah
like all the flow going to this one
vertex yes so that just to make sure
that every edge that crosses the set is
in the same component as the vertebra as
the backbone because then we know that
they must be in this one component
you have the back one for free you add
that in yes well it's not free it's like
constant times the optimum so that's
what yeah okay so what I wanted to say
just for okay we now have it four months
set but basically with very similar
arguments it just becomes more technical
you can show that you can kind of split
your flu such that any edge which
crosses just any single one in our
laminar family will go to the backbone
so we can do this same like forcing idea
for like a general family every new
every edge either has a node weighted
cost or it is immersed into this giant
component so that's kind of the general
idea okay so I told you the beginning
and the end of the road now how do we
get these vertebra pairs I have one
minute left so let me just give you a
very few slides so idea okay is all sets
in my family in my laminar family are
single turns and we are back at the node
waited case we are not there we would
like to reduce our laminar family and
the natural thing to do is to try to
contract some of these sets in the
family now what we do we kind of define
a notion of reducibility
which so let me first start with what's
an irreducible set so set as in the
feminist irreducible if i have two nodes
more precisely an endpoint of an
incoming and an endpoint of an outgoing
nud such that if i take the shortest
path inside the set between these two
nodes that will like be if almost like a
path a tsp inside this set that is it
visits most of the sets and by most I
mean in terms of the fraction of the
total cost and then an irreducible
instance is a set where you have all
this now I had slides illustrating this
but I kind of expect it to be the
variant here so I just put here
picture from a puzzle book of my
children so they always have these
puzzles that Fred has to get to the
pyramid but he has to avoid all these
scorpions and spiky palm trees and all
these desert things and so there is
typically just one way to go and it so
happens that this one they kind of
visits everything on the picture so
that's kind of at irreducible means that
really there is this shortest path which
behaves like almost like an 80s beat or
now the reducible set is the opposite
for any two points in the set if they
are connected there is a fairly short
connection between them which I'm not
going to quantify now but those are the
ones we can contract and then here we'll
have like the reduction which is kind of
careful recursive algorithm that if
someone gives us a route approximation
for irreducible instances then we can
get a an a true approximation for any
instances and then just one quick slide
on how does where where does this like
backbone come from so again this is what
Rico but the backbone is I have my
laminar family and I want to cross every
set in the laminar family so now I start
by contracting all the maximal sets in
my laminar family very good that's kind
of a nude weighted instance I can solve
this now I want to blow it back to the
original graph so I take so so here I
have contracted all the sets and I have
my tour visiting every one and it's a
constant wait so now I want to blow back
this set so here there is an incoming
edge and an outgoing there are loose end
points between them and now I need to
contact them I want to call
connect them in a pessimistic way I kind
of pretend that they are really this
unlucky pair of Fred and the pyramid who
I have to visit almost everyone between
them if it should not be the case then I
from here go to Fred and from the
pyramid I go to the outgoing so like I
can find paths inside which visit like
inside each maximal setting the family I
cross at least three-quarters of the
values of these sets and the value is
like the sum of the duals inside this
set if what I have here already crosses
everything in the laminar family then
that's our backbone if it does not then
there is actually there are two
recursive algorithms in here then I can
use that for every set in the laminar
family which is non trivalent is not
crossed by my set like all their total
weight is at moves like water of the
total LP solution so yeah I'd remove
some slides where these value things are
defined but this is like the optimal
solution and then I can like do
recursion on all these components and
that that will make the thing work at
the end okay but so yeah if you enter
you're more about these reductions then
I'm very happy to give more details next
week but then these complete finally the
whole picture so there's the constant
coming 5500 which is you know kind of
bigger than the logarithm of any number
out there in the world but it's still a
constant so we aim to get like the
simplest possible presentation which is
already like quite lengthy one could
squeeze it a bit more get it down to a
few thousands one could pull out claims
you can open up his black box and
instead of reducing to judges adjust the
general reduction it's a structured
thing and then one could get very down
to a few hundreds but well like I think
like getting beyond below a hundred is
is not really on the cards with this
instead approach we are doing
and well sentries are still out there
and still waiting to provide a another
approach actually like that would imply
a more robust and more general set of
results for example bottleneck at ESP
you could would be able to solve it thin
trees hopefully whereas this approach
doesn't seem to go there and David
kindly reminded us every decent TSP talk
should end with the question is there
better than three half for symmetric TSP
so I quickly added this final question
as deep-sea board me to you know to have
this here and yeah finally and at
placement so I'm looking for postdocs
and students to European research cancer
grant I'm starting next year which is
like very much in the theme of this
workshop for scaling methods for
discrete and continuous optimization so
if you are interested or know someone
interested them come talk to me please
thank you very much
persons
so always producible or so a set is
always reducible or irreducible so these
are defined as complementary notions
however it's not quite like we can
contract any reducible set so it's kind
of a more global thing like it's if I
have an algorithm for the irreducible
then I can use that as a black box to
solve instances which include reducible
sets so it's not like I can take any
reducible set and contracted
if you look at the solution you obtain
at the end before doing the short
cutting is the in degree of every
context at most five thousand five
hundred one let's say eleven thousand
yeah that actually depends on like Gulas
reduction for how you get from the local
connectivity a TSP to the solution and
like in terms of our reductions we
preserve the degrees but yeah I'm not
I'd need to think about what happens in
that black box in terms of the degrees
laminar families come a father problems
where a relaxation right any idea that
you can use so that like
yeah I mean here like lemon our family
is like one key properties like that
they give us this nice cause structure
and then the other is that we want to
contract demand recurs that way so I
guess if you have these like features in
the problem but yeah I don't know if any
other example yet where we could use
this
no I mean so we haven't or at least I
haven't looked at that yet but I think
there was some some non-trivial issue
there but I good
because the 5500 you get is is with
respect to the LP yes that's with
respect to the health corpse yes
[Applause]